uh oh party time i love being single i'm
really looking forward to it all the
apps getting on the apps yeah that's
gonna be cool swipe left swipe right
who's ugly
noah he was the love of my life
damn it
that is the love of mine
[Music]
they're like fully in new relationships
she's leaving me for a middle school
drama teacher can't take it with this
guy look at that bio artist
human oh you're a human man i bet he's a
chill hang on
we can't give up we have to get them
back really think we can break them up
in like no time it's on
you could become noah's friend i'm
extremely affable make him realize that
i am the one that got away
i could seduce logan i'm wondering how
you would feel about me joining you in
your bed yeah
ow
this is like cruel intentions only
sexier
how is it sexier
it's not
okay get in there and turn his eye
are you ready to give all this up you
know popping bottles with the boys
grinding with the honeys
you remind me of that little singing uh
cartoon gerbil alvin the chipmunk yes
okay yes
like a dermatologist's dream
[Music]
i've never done molly
is my heart going to explode no no
you're thinking a crack bro that's what
it was forget what happened
[Music]
can't believe we didn't think this part
all the way through we did not think
about that
[Music]
hey baby i want you back
[Music]
you